[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sail
israels heute gibt es mal wieder eine
adventssonntags torte ich werde eine
maritime torte backen wie sie aber ende
aussieht weiß ich jetzt nämlich das
überlege ich mir einfach im verlauf des
videos aber zuerst einmal packe ich
jetzt einen biscuit biskuit ist wirklich
super schnell und einfach gebacken
vor allem ist er schnell zubereitet
schnell gebacken und schnell abgekühlt
das heißt wenn ihr heute am sonntag ganz
spontan backen wollte packt einen
biscuit und die grundzutaten vom bizkit
sind wirklich nur eier zucker und mehl
und alles andere was dazukommt vanille
extrakt salz oder dia maritime kekse das
dient einfach den besseren geschmack
oder dem anderen geschmack
ich sage euch mal die zutaten für den
bizkit nämlich fünf eier etwas vanille
extrakt 200 gramm zucker und eine prise
salz 200 g mehl und 100 gramm martini
und ihr gebt jetzt einfach die eier die
sind schon zimmer war in eine große
rührschüssel ein handrührgerät
funktioniert natürlich auch dann etwas
vanille extrakt dann noch salz und
zucker mit rein
ihr könnt hier übrigens auch beim bhc
ist wird gerne statt zucker kokos
blutzucker verwenden
ich hatte da mal ein video gemacht über
den mandelkuchen mandelöl teig und hab
da einfach zucker durch kokos blüten
zucker oder durch die hälfte des zuckers
ausgetauscht und noch beten zucker
verwendet und das seht ihr wie die
verschiedenen zuckerarten werden in
einem kuchen und diese masse wird jetzt
für etwa 10 bis 15 minuten verrührt bis
zu wirklich schön weiß cremig ist und
dickflüssig ist genauso brauchen wir
nämlich den biscuit und dann kommt ja
auch ganz ohne backpulver aus und ohne
eier trennen
genau so sollte die masse aussehen schön
dick cremig das kann ich hier das mehl
dazugeben
am besten dazu sieben damit die
klümpchen entfernt werden und die
americana kekse die zerbröselte einfach
in der hand dass es nicht weil ich mir
ja stark bin sondern weil die kekse
einfach mega tat sind okay ich wollte
nicht fallen
ja ich bin mega shark ich zeige es nur
nicht
und jetzt vorsichtig unterheben
[Musik]
und hier habe ich jetzt einen tortenring
bereits eingestellt auf 26 cm
durchmesser auf eine back folie gesetzt
und die ist eben hier auf dem lochblech
und hier kommt jetzt der biscuit rein
also wäre da der hefeteig nicht wäre
glaube ich da biscuit so mein
lieblingsteil weil er eben so einfach
ist aber kein auch mehrere sein
lieblingsteil ja mein zweiter lieblings
trägt und der rührteig jetzt vorsichtig
hier verstreichen
und so kann er direkt schon gebacken
werden und ich nutze die backzeit aus
und macht schon mal eine frucht einlage
[Musik]
stattdessen könnt ihr natürlich auch
anderes obst nehmen andere früchte
nehmen ich habe jetzt die kirschen weil
die für mich schon so ein bisschen
weihnachtlich sind und ich finde die
kirschen fassen auch kurz ua martin i
aber wenn er hin wollte könnt ihr auch
gerne hin beim nehmen oder eben auch was
aus der dose das geht auch ich habe
jetzt hier platine und zwar ist das
einfach agar agar und das ist wirklich
einfach zu portionieren viel habe ich
immer gefragt mit dem agatha mit dem
pulver weil ich eben immer die gramm
angabe angeht und wenn ich dann mal 75
gramm habe ist die dosierung bisschen
schwieriger ich hab des praktischen
plattformen also wie gelatine nur eben
begann und dann habt ihr hier einfach
zwei blätter und ein blatt blatt
gelatine ersetzt praktisch drei blatt
gelatine und ich habe das jetzt bereits
runtergerechnet und gerade bei früchten
mit viel säure verwendet man dann
einfach die doppelte menge
weil die eben mehr bindekraft brauchen
hier benutze ich jetzt zwei blatt lasse
ich aber jetzt hier noch kurz stehen der
unterschied zwischen gelatine und agatha
ist nämlich man muss das aber nicht
vorher in wasser aufweichen das heißt
man hat da auch keinen zusätzlichen
arbeitsschritt oder zeitaufwand das wird
gleich direkt mit erfülle mit der masse
einfach aufgekocht ich werde jetzt hier
die kirchen mit dem wasser kurz pürieren
[Musik]
und falls ihr euch fragen sollte warum
nimmt sie den ich einfach kirschen aus
dem glas die haben sowieso schon
mehrfach war mit dabei das hier ist die
farbe
ich bin tief gefrorene kirschen die
haben einfach noch diese schöne rote
kirsch farbe und die aus dem glas die
sind eher so ein bisschen lila und
deswegen nehme ich jetzt die mal die
echt schöner sind jetzt kommt das
deckkraft sozusagen das kirsch püree
hier in den topf zimt und nelken kommen
auch mit dazu und die plakative hier mit
rein jetzt in heerdt anschalten und dann
muss es ganz normal wie bei agatha eben
auch zwei minuten lang sprudelnd kochen
also erst kurz warten bis es kocht und
dann ab dann messe ich immer die zeit im
stop die zeitung macht dann erst die
zwei minuten
ansonsten haben nämlich keine bindekraft
bevor ihr jetzt die frucht einlage in
eurer form ein fühlt macht sich am
besten die probe und zwar nehmt ihr
jetzt einfach ein bisschen was davon
gibt es in einen kleinen teller und
stellt gleich mal in den kühlschrank und
so könnt ihr nämlich kontrollieren ob
die masse fest wird denn so eine kleine
menge wird innerhalb von einer minute
etwa fest und wenn sie nicht fest ist
heißt es dass agatha hat nicht
ausgereicht und wenn sie fest wird wisst
ihr ich kam zweiter verarbeiten
und hier sieht man jetzt einfach dass
die probe wirklich fest wurde
also ich kann sie nicht mal so einen
finger verschieben wirklich nur mit
gewalt und da ist sehr schön fest und
jetzt braucht ihr gar keine spezielle
backform sondern nehmt einfach einen
tiefen teller oder native schale legte
mit frischhaltefolie aus einzieht denn
ich möchte er die zimtstange und nelken
nicht mit den der torte haben könnten
auch machen solche überraschungen
darauf weist hat was gewonnen aber wenn
nämlich lieber raus deswegen hier
durchlaufen lassen
[Musik]
da steht es im stammsitz
aber wo ist die nelke wie sieht denn ja
heißen nicht drin also kann ich das hier
ein kippen und größeres dann klappt's wo
ist die vizrt ihr was wir machen ein
suchspiel draußen stange ist weg und ich
meine wenn offene land gereist ist auch
gar nicht schlimm denn anthony hat mir
meine mama freigegeben wenn ich
zahnschmerzen hatte muss sich auf eine
nelke beißen denn das betäubt so ein
bisschen den schmerz gleich zwei kleben
fliegen mit einer klappe denn die torte
zahnschmerzen verursacht dann stellen
wir den zuschlag und die zehen steigen
hat dann auf keinen fall wegschmeißen
sondern auswaschen unter kaltem oder
fließenden wasser und dann könnte die
noch weiter benutzen denn die hat noch
ganz viel aroma entweder noch mal für
eine frucht einlage oder von
kinderpunsch oder eben auch für den
glühwein raketen es lockert es hier am
rand gerne immer ein bisschen damit die
folie wirklich auch schön flach auf dem
teller auflegt und die frucht einlage
schön wird und dann kann sie jetzt so
erstmal abkühlen und dann in den
gefrierschrank und komplett einfrieren
so sieht der fertige biscuit aus
wirklich perfekt und ich ziehe ihn dann
immer ganz gerne direkt von dem
backblech runter rauf ein abkühlen
gitter das lasse ich ihnen für etwa fünf
minuten später stehen jetzt lasse ich
jeden feld war fünf minuten stehen und
dann löse ich ihnen aus der form heraus
und stürzt ihn raus und dann lasse ich
ihn komplett abgehört
[Musik]
nach dem vollständigen abkühlen könnt
ihr auch die back folie wegziehen und
den biss wird dann einmal durchschneiden
ich habe mich gerade echt ein bisschen
erschrocken und dachte oh gott wie sieht
mein bizkit aus jetzt fällt mir wieder
ein ich hab doch am maritim kekse drin
und die hingen deswegen auch am rand der
form so ein bisschen fest und beim
schneiden war es ein bisschen
schwieriger daher bröselte ist ein wenig
so jetzt kann ich jedenfalls hier
das zur seite stellen und schon mal die
creme zu bereiten für die creme nämlich
500 gramm mascarpone 100 gramm
puderzucker 600 gramm sahne etwas tonga
für das aroma und salat zum festigen und
ich nehme jetzt erst einmal die
mascarpone in die röhre schüsse da kommt
der puderzucker mit dazu tonka bonga
kann auch gleich mit rein
ihr könnt auch eine tonkabohne nehmen
und ein bisschen was abtreiben oder
einfach davon eine telefonisch rühren
ich noch nicht nach vorne sondern wir
sind und ich lasse jetzt gebe ich hier
langsam die sahne dazu
und kann dann die masse mit seiner fahrt
steif schlagen
der chef ein bisschen sana und terror
objektiv etwas leider ein bisschen zu
schnell geht
ich habe jetzt den tortenboden wenn ihr
daran denkt könnt ihr den tortenboden
stürzen und dann den boden als deckel
nehmen
ich weiß nicht mehr daran gedacht das
lege ich hier einen tortenring außen rum
und die frucht einlage drauf sie sitzt
fest und gefroren und hier kommt jetzt
die leckere tanker creme hinein
[Musik]
schön verteilen
den rand her mache ich dann immer mit so
einem teig habe einfach wieder sauber
[Musik]
das kann ich heute ganz kurz zur seite
stellen und den deckel nehmen und da hab
ich jetzt hier das problem ich habe hier
schon 23 löcher drin
das macht gar nichts ich wollte nämlich
sowieso einen stern ausstecher nehmen
und hier oben sterne ausstechen
das heißt geht erst mal an dieser stelle
schlechten stellen aus und deswegen habe
ich eben auch sagt wenn er früher dran
denkt wirklich den boden stürzen und den
boden als deckel nehmen
das nehme ich auch immer ein bisschen
weicher da oben ist immer ein bisschen
knuspriger erstmal durch die
parallelisierung
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich schon mal direkt etwas
glitzer schnee und der kommt jetzt hier
auf den decken
[Musik]
dann der decke vorsichtig auf die torte
die sterne hier gebe ich jetzt noch auf
kann die torte kurz in den kühlschrank
stellen und dann reden wir sie nach der
schulzeit sollen etwa zwei stunden
fertig jetzt die torte durchgeführt und
ich ziehe sie direkt auf'm eine
tortenplatte und hier habe ich jetzt ein
bisschen marmelade erwärmt ihr könnt
entweder eine kirsche marmelade nehmen
oder eine mehr frucht marmelade
hauptsache was schönes rotes und das
dann in einen gefrierbeutel oder
spritzbeutel einfüllen und damit fühle
ich jetzt gleich diese ständchen aus und
dann hat man einen schönen farbkontrast
[Musik]
dann können wir das so ein bisschen in
die spitzen reindrücken verteilt sich
auch schön
[Musik]
die torte anschneiden und murat darf
probieren ja und heute bist du nicht
alleine hallo ich habe heute den jens
dabei kommen jens ist ein kreuz mit dem
games haben uns zusammen kandidaten
wieder abgebaut und gedacht hey guck mal
kurz vor weihnachten bei uns vorbei so
ist es und ich sage immer wenn besuchen
kommt dann muss auch für die kamera oder
ja so jens ist dass jeder der in die
küche kommt während wir drehen muss
einmal in die kamera winken also das
jetzt so eine torte ich finde es so eine
art wenz torte du kannst du jetzt nur
ein fall sei er letztlich ohnehin schon
ist musste ich muss nicht nur alle
schmecken ja das probiere es wirklich wo
wir wirklich sehr tat dies einfach zu
machen aber ich find's toll übel es ist
echt so wenn ich es probiert es immer
gut sagen die leute hier schmeckt mir
immer ob man so gut geschmeckt hat du
hast mir gesagt ich soll der einfach
sagen wenn es schmeckt unterwegs sein
kann ja nicht so schmeckt das ist
einfach verdammt
es ist verdammt lecker gemacht ich fange
jetzt nicht so toll jetzt ehrlich sagen
schmeckt sich doch ist natürlichen
wechsel sollte immer schon auch comics
haben sie schon geschrieben habe sie 100
prozent natürlich nichts verborgen
geschmeckt sonst ja wirklich ohne 65 vor
allem halte die technik mit dem stern
und mega einfach ihr könnt zum beispiel
auch diese technik anwenden am
valentinstag oder muttertag und kleine
herzchen ausstechen und das sieht auch
megacities aus und im prinzip ist die
torte superschnell gemacht gerade mal so
für sonntag hat normalerweise alle
zutaten da ich zumindest ihr vielleicht
nicht die schon weit weg von zu hause
familie kommt ja und dann so eine
weihnachtskarte als nach wunsch auch mit
dieser frucht das ist einfach nur ein
bruchteil an beinahe jedem zusteht
nämlich noch die kosten aber naja also
falls ihr die torte nach machen wollt
schaut doch sallys - blog.de wobei oder
in der kostenlosen app viel spaß beim
nachbacken und ich freue mich schon
richtig auf eure standorte und kleiner
tannenbaum torten oder hohlbein 80
dollar
bis dahin ist noch ein bisschen aber das
wissen sie zu einer echten also bis dann
vielleicht diesen sommertagen nämlich
schon aber er merkt du nach hause denn
auch bildern ins büro muss morgens -
auto das handy gar nicht im auto lassen
und muss der 1
[Musik]